my experience of American food sometimes
there's strange ingredients so when I
try something new I get a bit nervous in
case it might kill me
biscuits and gravy sounds exceptionally
weird biscuit in England is basically a
cookie and gravy is usually what you put
on like mashed potatoes or roast dinner
so biscuits and gravy are two things
that should never be put together
honestly it looks like sick it looks
like a cake with carbonara sauce on it
it smells like car tires what ins up
horrible mmm well you should be for
prisoners it doesn't taste like anything
really salty that's so salty it's like
you you know that spray you get a smoke
spray even like add two things it's like
someone just went like all over it but I
don't I don't mind the gravy is creamy
yeah if you just have the sauce on its
own it just tastes like a really cheap
microwave pasta dish
but then you can't ignore that 90
percent of it is the gun off sponge it's
not disgusting like I don't hate it I
can see it probably fills you up if
you're hungry like student food maybe
Americans would like I don't think
English people would ever enjoy this
especially at breakfast we call these
scones back home and you would put jam
and cream on them England has a lot of
strange foods that we think in normal
and just coming out to America I realize
how strange of cuisine seems to people
this is not something I would seek out
again it doesn't taste amazing but I can
imagine if you've grown up with it it
would give you a sense of comfort it is
that comfort food and doesn't make sense
in my brain because we grew up with
something completely different so it's
just a cultural difference and it
shouldn't really be to mean about it
it's just so sad what's happening over
there oh yeah you don't know the half of
it